nbc news targets the federalist with
destruction with google's help
former vice presidential candidate tim
kaine gives a very interesting lesson
on american slavery and president trump
issues an executive order on policing
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn protect your online privacy
today at expressvpn.com
ben we're going to get to all the news
and boy is there plenty of it
all of it's stupid we'll get to all of
the stupid news in just one second first
you may have noticed things are rather
uncertain right now the stock market is
bouncing up and down
like a yo-yo maybe you've made money
maybe you've lost money who the hell
knows it's all over the place
one thing that you do know is going to
happen is that at some point the dollar
is probably going to weaken it's going
to inflate and that means it'll be a
good idea to make sure that you die
that you at least diversify into
precious metals at least a little bit
right now and you know what i'm going to
say my friends over at birch gold that's
the place
to do it last thursday the dow dropped
1700 points in the opening hours because
of fear of coronavirus resurgence or of
the fed spending
too much money they might spend 10
trillion dollars this year well
again good time to diversify into
precious metals we've been smart to do
it a few months ago and i told you too
but you can still do it right now all
you have to do
is text ben to 47 47 47 diversifying 10
or 20
of your portfolio into precious metals
might be a good idea when you purchase
on or before july 31st you get a free
signed copy of my book
the right side of history birch gold
will go to work for you and make things
super simple text ben to 247 4747 at
least request a free information kit on
diversifying and go ask all your
questions you'll feel better about it
there is no obligation birch gold group
has thousands of satisfied customers
countless five star reviews
a plus rating with the better business
bureau tech spends 47 47 47 again
during the months of june or july when
you open an ira in precious metals you
get a signed copy of my magical book the
right side of history for free again
text pen
to 47 47 47 and just as a financial
matter you should be at least a little
diversified into precious metals with
all of the chaos and uncertainty
right now okay so we begin with the big
media story of the day so the media have
just
clowned themselves over the past few
months they've absolutely become
themselves they've clowned themselves on
coronavirus
because they suggested that chronovirus
was super serious until exactly the
moment when people decided to rush out
into the streets and protest on
massachusetts when coronavirus
became not serious at all they become
themselves
on police violence by suggesting that
the police all across the country
are racist and systemically shooting
black men which is not true
they've declared themselves on
everything from impeachment to
russiagate i mean it's just a it's an
insane level of be clowning each and
every day but
they've always been able to hide behind
the idea that they were journalists and
not activists well now the mask is
coming off obviously because
in the midst of the george floyd protest
we saw the new york times basically
caved directly to the activist wing of
its own journalistic institution we saw
its woke staffers bully out
the editorial op-ed page manager who of
course was on the left we saw the
philadelphia inquirer get rid of one of
its editors specifically because
he was not woke enough despite the fact
that he had diversified the newsroom
so all of this was coming out right it
was very clear that the
journalistic objectivity that was
purported to reign at a lot of these
institutions
was bull crap well the the mask finally
fell for i think what is the most clear
time
last night and in the process also
unmasked a lot of the
big tech companies particularly google
specifically google because i don't
think all big tech companies are quite
the same on this stuff
google particularly for being
unbelievably hypocritical in taking
advantage of section 230 of the
communications decency act
which shields websites from being
policed for their comment sections right
shields them from liability for their
comment sections
google decided that it would go after
the federalist
right wing outlet would go after the
federalists for its comment section
and nbc news was the leading driver here
so there's something that a lot of news
organizations do
these days when it comes to policing
their competitors
what they will do is they will go to
advertisers on a particular show like
say tucker carlson
this is the way that this works they get
some sort of notice from a group like
media matters the tucker has said
something controversial
and media matters has taken him out of
context to suggest that he is a racist
and then they will go to all the
advertisers and in the guise of news
gathering
these outlets and these reporters will
say so you're still advertising on
tucker carlson
now that's not news that's activism
because the basic idea there is
we're going to report it if you don't
drop the advertising right we are going
to make an issue of it
if you don't drop the advertising on
tucker carlson you are responsible for
the stuff that tucker carlson says so
that's long been
the sort of nexus between the open
activism of groups like media matters
and the so-called journalism of a lot of
members of the media who are willing to
run with that narrative and are willing
to
quote unquote ask questions but ask
questions to achieve a certain purpose
so yesterday the mask came off
completely like completely came off
so nbc news is a reporter named adele
momoko frazier
and who reported on tuesday that google
had banned the federalist from its
advertising platform
the supposed prohibition came after nbc
approached google with allegedly
problematic articles featured
on the federalist website this by
beckett adams over at washington
examiner
a spokeswoman then told the federalist
that the federalist has not
told the washington examiner that the
federalist is not currently demonetized
but here is the entire story
a british non-profit group is called the
center for countering digital hate these
groups have basically been set up with
shoddy incredibly shoddy research this
has been going on for several years
these are the same sorts of groups
that suggest that people like dave rubin
or jordan peterson or
joe rogan or i are directing people
toward white supremacist ideology
right it's all of this nonsense that
they promote that suggest that if you
are a typical
conservative or not even conservative
that if you stand up for the idea
that men and women are different for
example that this is driving people
toward white supremacy doesn't matter
how many times
you yourself have led the charge against
the alt-right you actually are all right
right
these groups exist in order to promote a
particular point of view of the world
which is that if you are right of karl
marx
then you are then you are in essence a
fascist and can be grouped with the
fascists okay so this british nonprofit
group is called the center for
countering digital hate
they published a paper that targeted 10
us-based websites that it said had
published racist criticisms
of the recent protests surrounding the
death of george floyd those websites the
non-profit group argued stand to make
millions of dollars
through google ads now their study was
crap there's no evidence that the
federalists per se
put forward any racist material on
george floyd and the articles they cite
are not actually racist
so what happens nbc does exactly what
i've talked about with regards to for
example tucker carlson immediate matters
nbc approaches google with the center
for countering digital hate
study demanding the tech giant do
something about it
now nbc's original story quoted a google
spokesperson who said quote
we have strict publisher policies that
govern the content ads can run on and
explicitly prohibit derogatory content
that promotes hatred intolerance
violence or discrimination based on race
from monetizing
adding one a page your site violates our
policies we take action in this case
we've removed the federalists ability to
monetize with google
a google spokesperson declined to
reconcile that above quote with the tech
company's current position
that it has not in fact demonetized the
federalist a spokesperson for the
federalist did not respond to the
washington examiner's request for
comment
the initial nbc report also included a
passage where the author bragged that it
was her news division
the ironically named verification unit
that approached google with the hate
study demanding the tech company do
something about the allegedly offensive
online
online content google blocked the
federal list from its advertising
platform
after the nbc news verification unit
brought the project to its attention
said the original report which has now
been retconned and removed
the federalist the nbc reporter
explained in a current version of the
write-up
has become well known in recent years
for publishing far-right articles on a
variety of subjects
it published an article claiming the
media had been lying about looting and
violence during the protests
which was included in the report sent to
google so the supposedly problematic
article by the way
is not racist it just points out that
the media have basically suggested if
you cover the writing and the looting
you are racist
google for its part disputed most of the
nbc's report
including the part where it said the
federalists came under scrutiny because
of specific articles instead
google says that the federalist comments
section was the problem
a spokesperson said we've been told the
federalists remove comments as of this
time
she added when our enforcement team
review sites they review the entire
site's content including the comment
section
for policy compliance in this instance
the notification to the federalist was
related to the comments section of the
site which is not a new policy
the comments sections consistently
violated our dangerous and derogatory
policy
okay then this reporter remember
reporter not activist reporter tweeted
out new
from nbc verification unit thanks to at
sf
fake news and ccdhate for their hard
work and collaboration
so openly saying like i'm collaborating
with these groups in order to take down
the federalist
thanks to them thanks to them okay so
obviously look nbc news is not a news
outlet
it is an activist outlet just
acknowledge that that's exactly what's
going on here there are two points worth
making
one is that it is perfectly obvious at
this point that
so many members of me not all of them
many members of the media are activists
in the disguise of journalists
so i'm glad this happened because it
just takes the mask right off it is
perfectly obvious and corporations
should know it and when a journalist
calls you for comment on the latest
thing tucker carlson has said
they're not calling you because they
care what you say they're calling you
because they're threatening you and
everyone knows
this everyone knows this okay this is
the dirty little game the dirty little
game is
all you got to do is get a reporter from
huffington post to call you up for a
comment
in order to drive an advertiser off a
show off a site
or off a particular outlet that's all
you have to do
because basically the huffington post
journalists are the
are the action wing of groups like media
matters right media matters isn't openly
calling for defunding
tucker carlson instead all they do is
they just send off to their email list
to the nbc news verification unit and to
the huffington post quote unquote
journalists
and they say look at this bad thing
somebody said today why don't you call
up their advertisers
call up their advertisers guys and oh
look at that it's news now it's news
because advertisers are dropping from
tucker carlson right this is the dirty
little game and now the game is out in
the open because nbc news
not only botched their own story right
they lit their verification unit printed
a story that was not true and had to
revise it
stealthily but not only did not only
that the nbc quote-unquote news unit
was directly driving the story in the
first place by going to
google and trying to have the federalist
demonetized so that's story number one
your journalistic activists are in fact
activists first and journalists second
and they are using their journalism as a
guise for their activism
it's a trojan horse okay so that is
story number one then there's story
number two and that is google
we're gonna get to google and their
policy that supposedly allows you to
demonetize based on comment sections
which is fully insane we're gonna get to
that in just one second first
let us talk about the fact that right
now bad time to go to the post office
you might like the post office but
standing in line at the post office in a
closed space
but probably not the best idea right now
instead why don't you just use
stamps.com first of all you'll save tons
of money also you'll save tons of time
even in the best of circumstances
schlepping your stuff over to the post
office is not exactly a great use
of your time instead head over to
stamps.com we've been using stamps.com
here at the daily wire since 2017
no more wasting our time stems.com
brings all the services of the us postal
service direct to your computer in the
safety and comfort of your own home
office anywhere else you're hunkering
down right now whether you're a small
business sending invoices an online
seller shipping out products or you're
just working from home
and you need to mail stuff stamps.com
can handle it all with ease
simply use your computer to print
official us postage 24 7
for any letter any package any class of
mail anywhere you want to send it and
once your mail is ready you just leave
it for the mail carrier you schedule a
free package pick up you drop into
mailbox no human contact required it is
very
very easy plus you get huge discounts
you get five cents off every first class
stamp up to 62 percent off shipping
right so this is a real no-brainer and
right now
my listeners get a special offer it
includes a four-week trial plus free
postage and digital skill
no long-term commitment just go to
stamps.com click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage type in shapiro
again that's stamps.com and then click
on that mic at the top of the homepage
type in shapiro four week trial plus
free postage and a digital scale go
check them out right now okay so that's
story number one is nbc news is
journalists who are actually activists
demonstrating full scale that they're
activists
and not journalists and i don't want to
hear from them anymore that when they
are calling
advertisers for comment then what
they're really doing is just
they're just seeking out the news no
you're making the news okay you guys are
nightcrawler
have you ever seen that movie with jake
gyllenhaal he starts off by basically
making money
covering car crashes and then he starts
staging the car crashes so he can make
money off of the car crashes right you
guys are jake gyllen gyllenhaal in
nightcrawler you're staging the crimes
you're participating in the crimes in
order so you can make money off of
photographing the crimes
so you get to you get to really enjoy
yourself all
always right you get to be an activist
and then you get to pretend that you're
actually just a reporter
okay but there's another story here that
is very telling and it makes it very
difficult for libertarians like me
okay so i'm libertarian when it comes to
big tech i think that big tech
these are private companies they get to
basically do what they want and so the
idea that we should be regulating big
tech i've always found very dicey
because i don't like the idea of
elizabeth warren at the head of some
editorial commission
determining whether a website is liable
or not liable for comments posted
in its comments section there's
something called section 230 of the
communications decency act this has
become very controversial
section 230 of the communications
decency act says that you are not liable
for your comments section essentially
that you are a platform so long as you
are an open thread
so that doesn't mean you can't curate
the open thread but it does mean that
you have to be an open thread right the
people who are posting the content do
not work for you
the people so youtube right is not
liable for the content posted by its
creators
so if i post something on youtube that
violates copyright youtube cannot be
sued
only i can be sued right that is the
basic idea of section 230 of the
communications decency act and it makes
some sense it was not designed
to suggest that you cannot curate in
fact section 230 was designed
specifically to stop people from
penalizing people who curate because
the the basic case behind section 230
was
why would you penalize a company that's
taking down for example pornography on
its site
as opposed to a company that just allows
pornography on its site
why would you why would you penalize
them right bottom line is the
distinction was between
platforms which allow open thread you
can put up what you want it can still be
curated
content and sites that pay people
to or independent contractors to put up
content on their site right like so
daily wire we actually
are sort of bifurcated in this way right
we have a comment section that we curate
but that we are not responsible for
illegally if someone posts something
derogatory in our comment section we are
not responsible for that
we'll work to take it down but we are
not responsible for it and then there
are our writers right and our writers
who are paid by us
if they say something that is legally
defamatory right then we are liable
right this is the law
under section 230 of the communications
decency act and google and youtube
and all the other open thread right all
the other platforms have relied on
section 230
because imagine for a second that you're
youtube and all of a sudden you're made
liable for every video that is placed on
your on your site
and there are literally millions of
hours placed on your site every single
day
right there's there's tons of content on
youtube that violates various legal
provisions
like tons of it tons of it okay and
let's say that youtube were made legal
legally liable for that
well youtube would not be in business
for more than 37 seconds right they
would be done right they'd be toast
and so they relied on section 230 of the
communications decency saying listen we
don't post all this content
we do our best to kind of curate it but
we don't post the content
okay fair enough right fair enough and
i've said okay and if you don't like how
they curate their content
well then form a different site right
you're perfectly welcome to do that it's
a free country
this lasts only so long as youtube and
google
actually hold themselves to the same
standard so google owns youtube
so according to this nbc news report
basically what happened here
is that google went to the federalists
and said you are not curating your
comments in the way
that we would like you to curate your
comments and therefore we are going to
talk about demonetizing you
so in other words the standard that
google was holding the federalists to
was
you are responsible for the comment
sections we are going to demonetize you
for your comment sections we are going
to remove the ability
for you to make money from google ads
because your comment sections are not
properly policed so in other words
you're responsible for your comment
sections we're not responsible for our
site
but you're responsible for your comment
sections right we cannot be held legally
liable
for the stuff that people are posting in
our comment section cause after all
that's an open thread
but you can be held liable by us for
the comments in your comment section
even though you didn't post them
it's gonna make it really difficult for
libertarians like me to stare down
senator josh halley from missouri when
he says okay hold up a second
google is is going to target people with
their comments sections while
maintaining that they are not liable for
their own comment sections
that sort of hypocrisy cannot stand
you're really going to go after people
for their comment sections now and then
you expect us
to treat you as completely free of legal
liability because after all
you're just a giant comment section it
don't work that way
right if you are going to suggest that
you actually get to exercise editorial
control over where ads land
based on comment sections well now
you're now you're a publisher right
you're treating yourself as a publisher
at this point
and because your editorial control has
gone so far that you are now
making actual advertising decisions
based on content appearing on somebody
else's comment section
so no we're not going to grant you that
that freedom from liability we'll
rewrite
section 230. one of the proposals that's
been made is that you should be granted
the right to sue
if these publishers if these platforms
rather
do not adhere to their own rules in fair
to even fashion
right so if twitter would take down uh a
racist
white person but not take down louis
farrakhan for example and again i've
stood against that because i don't think
the government really has a place here
but
if these institutions are going to act
as the worst kind of government that i
decry
it becomes very difficult for me to
argue in favor of the libertarian
position
so google is just the mask is off at
google too they don't care about youtube
they don't care about any semblance of
freedom of speech because they're going
after people's comments section and
that's a pretext by the way
this is a pretext i don't believe
google's story i think what actually
happened
is that they saw an article they didn't
like the article they decided to
penalize the federalist the blowback was
too harsh so they decided to blame the
comment section
and they went directly from the frying
pan into the fire because it turns out
it is worse to police a site based on
its comment section then it is to police
a site
based on the articles that it posts all
of this is insane
because we've now reached the censorious
the censorious regime desired by the
left
where rights are bad so long as they are
exercised by people you don't like
all right coming up we're going to talk
about a a a couple of other examples of
media bias one from popular mechanics i
mean if you talk about losing the
culture war this is losing the culture
war in stunning fashion we're gonna get
to that in just
one second first let's talk about the
fact that sleep is very hard to come by
these days there are all sorts of
studies saying people are not sleeping
as well
during the pandemic which of course
makes a lot of sense and there's a lot
of stress out there
i'm stuck at home in my house with three
young children
this is very stressful it's very very
stressful dirty little secrets school is
designed to remove children from the
from their parents for a few hours a day
so you miss them but the reality is that
you go to bed at night and it's like oh
god so much nervous tension
you need bull and branch sheets you do
bowling brand sheets these are
the best sheets bowling branch epitomize
is an american business success story
they don't just make sheets and bedding
pillows and towels
all sorts of comfortable things for your
home with your help they put thousands
of people to work around the world from
their pillows made in cincinnati ohio
their mattresses made in florida texas
and arizona since they started
six years ago my bowling brand sheets
excellent example of something
that feels small when you treat yourself
to it but then you realize it's not
because you're spending
hours every day on these sheets they are
incredibly comfortable in fact they're
so comfortable they've ruined other
sheets for me i cannot sleep on anything
other than bull and branch like when i'm
at a hotel
in the not pandemic times and i'm
sleeping on sheets that are not bowling
branch it just doesn't work as well
bowling brand sheets are wonderful they
are breathable they get softer with time
remember you'll only find bowling brand
sheets online it's spelled b-o-l-l
and branch dot com if now's the time to
make such a purchase
use code ben shapiro get 50 off your
first set of sheets which is a great
deal again shipping is fast and free
restrictions may apply see bull and
branch dot com for details that's
b-o-l-l
and branch dot com right now use code
ben shapiro get 50 bucks off
your first set of sheets okay meanwhile
speaking of media bias so popular
mechanics put up an article titled how
to topple a statue using science
how to topple a statue using science
popular mechanics
they're going to teach you about using
levers it's really exciting stuff
you can safely topple a statue using
science because it's very important
right now
you need to know how to topple a statue
i really look forward to popular
mechanics next article how to build a
molotov cocktail
very important important stuff but don't
worry guys it's not activism it's just
journalism
it's just journalism how to topple a
statue now all of this is tobacco
narrative right all of this is tobacco
particular narrative america is deeply
systemically evil all of its
institutions are shot through
with evil and those who do not buy into
the narrative must
be punished must be punished
the best example of this is a truly
horrific article
from the new york times this insane
article from the new york times
focuses on high school students and alum
it's called high school students and
alumni are using social media to expose
racism
learning has been online and remote this
semester so too now are callouts of
questionable behavior
questionable so we're going to call out
high school students now very very
important okay so
let me give my perspective on high
school students generally high school
students
are idiots i was one once high school
students are dumb
meaning that they my first rule i get
asked for advice from high school
students on a routine basis
and they say do you have a piece of
advice for us it's like stay away from
social media because everything you do
on social media lives forever
i started writing a syndicated column at
age 17. most of my worst columns were
written from ages 18 to 21.
right when you are when you are young
you are full of vinegar and pep and
stupidity
and you are more likely to post
something that you are going to regret
later i have a whole list of things
online
about the things i regret having said
over the years well if you're posting
stuff on social media when you're 15 16
years old
chances are very good you're going to
post something incredibly idiotic and or
offensive
now the way normally you would deal with
that in a typical scenario let's say
there were no social media
somebody would say something offensive
in class right or something would say
something offensive to a friend
and then the friend would go to the to
the friend and say you know that really
hurt my feelings you really shouldn't
stay off like that that was offensive
maybe you didn't mean to offend me i
don't know but you really shouldn't say
stuff like that
and that would give the person a chance
for repentance and for making themselves
better
right that would be the idea and i'm not
speaking you know out of school here
when i was when i was in high school as
i've talked about before i was viciously
bullied and i don't just mean people
calling me names i mean
actual hardcore physical abuse i mean
people hitting me with belts and such
i mean like like really not great stuff
when i was in high school
now i know the names of all the people
who did that i still remember all their
names i remember all their faces
many of them are still people in my
social circles i remember all of them
i've never said the names nor will i say
the names because these kids were idiots
they were 16 17 years old
they're morons and we handled all of
this
internally right we had discussions with
the principal i didn't feel like justice
was done
but my what i did figure and what i
still figure is that people
have to move beyond what they were at 15
or 16 years old and you have to give
them the opportunity to move
beyond what they were when they were 15
or 16 years old is particularly true
when you're talking about mine was an
extreme case with physical abuse when
you're talking about what people say
it seems to me that this is triply or
quadruply true you say something dumb
when you're 15 or 16 years old
you shouldn't be held accountable at 30
or 35 for it nor
should you be publicly shamed when
you're 15 or 16 for it somebody should
come to you behind the scenes a mentor
an elder figure somebody from the
community and say you know you really
shouldn't have said that that was really
bad you should apologize to the person
you hurt and then you should move on
with your life and act better
because guess what being young is a time
when you are supposed to make yourself
better
right people don't change very much
beyond the age of 30 maybe but when
you're 15 or 16 there's a lot of change
going on
now the new york times is writing full
scale articles on why it is good to
social media shame high school students
who post dumb and or racist crap online
and i'm just wondering
isn't it possible to help them course
correct their behavior
without this sort of stuff and by the
way this goes for black white and green
if you're a 15 year old kid living in
the inner city and you post something
really awful online
i don't think that should ruin your life
and i don't think you should be publicly
shamed for that
it's one thing to commit a crime white
black or green it is another thing to
say something
offensive white black or green because
people say dumb stuff when they're 14 or
15 years old
now the new york times is really
promoting this idea that what's good is
this public shaming ritual
and it's got to extend all the way down
to childhood so the new york times has a
very very long article by taylor lorenz
and catherine rosman again this is
activism masquerading as journalism
because it's actually pushing the agenda
called high school students and alumni
are using social media to expose
racism over the past few weeks as the
black lives matter movement has grown
following outrage over the killing of
george floyd
high school students have leveraged
every social media platform to call out
their peers for racist behavior
very important stuff you're making the
world a better place by taking little
jessica who said a very bad thing online
and then exposing her to the minions of
hatred in the boob box over at twitter
very very important you couldn't just go
onto jessica and said you know that was
offensive you might want to take that
down
you could have been a decent human being
right instead you decided
the public must be we have to justine
sacko this person
we have to publicly shame this 16 year
old students have repurposed large meme
accounts set up google docs and
anonymous pages on instagram snapchat
and twitter and wielded their personal
followings to hold friends and
classmates accountable for behavior
they deem unacceptable but they're not
holding them accountable
all they're doing is ruining their lives
right accountability would be you go to
somebody and you correct
the behavior that's holding them
accountable people will post videos of
people saying the n-word or videos where
they're being racist or using derogatory
words and stuff like that
and they go viral so that's sofia
giannata16 a sophomore at whitesboro
high school in whitesboro new york where
a teacher was recently criticized for
stating that all lives matter in a
virtual school event he later apologized
question how is all lives matter like a
great example
of such vicious racism that you require
public ostracization
and public apology on june 2 an
anonymous instagram account dedicated to
exposing racism at san marcos high
school in san marcos california appeared
online
oh c.s naphtali garcia 19 a senior
noticed it almost immediately
the account was shared across group
chats and instagram stories within a few
hours had amassed about 900
new followers the account began sharing
screenshots and videos of students at
school using racial slurs engaging in
cultural appropriation participating in
the george floyd challenge i mean all
this is ugly stuff and making
insensitive remarks
the names and handles for each student
were included in the post within 48
hours the account had grown to nearly 3
000 followers and this is the key right
it's all about the virtue signaling of
the followers it's not about correcting
the sins of the people who are sinning
it's about all these people following so
they can hit the click the like the
retweet
and then they can spread out the shame
i've participated in the correction of
this person's bit no you've corrected
you participated in the destruction of
this person who could have been course
corrected
who could have been course corrected
because i assume when you're 16 or 15
you can be course corrected and i think
it's a fairly safe assumption
it's one of the key assumptions of
american criminal law for juveniles by
the way we're going to get some more of
this in just one second first
let's talk about the fact that a lot of
people worry right now about can they
buy life insurance the answer is yes
you can indeed buy life insurance and if
you have loved ones depending on your
income you probably should it's the
smart thing to do
under any circumstances when there's an
increased chance of plotting well this
would be a good time to get your life
insurance policy genius is in contact
with the life insurance companies on
their platform every day they're keeping
track of all the changes in the market
so you don't have to
that means they can get you covered
quickly and for the best price here's
how it works
policy genius compares quotes from the
top life insurance companies all in one
place
it takes just a few minutes to compare
quotes from the top insurers and find
your best price
this doesn't just save a lot of legwork
you could say 1500 bucks or more a year
by using policy genius to compare life
insurance policies once you apply
the policy genius team will handle all
the paperwork and the red tape for free
so if you hit any speed bumps during the
application process they will take care
of
everything for you they don't just do
life insurance by the way they do auto
insurance and they do disability
insurance
all sorts of stuff so go check them out
right now at policygenius.com they will
find you the best rate handle the
process completely soup to nuts will get
you and your family protected hopefully
give you
one less thing to worry about go check
them out right now at policygenius.com
again and that is policygenius.com so
again the new york times promoting this
idea that this is very good
these call out pages they're very good
these pages are popping up left and
right said ethan ramirez 18
a graduate of bowie high school in
austin texas there's ones that are
region specific
high school specific district specific
several large meme accounts have also
now devoted themselves to exposing
racist behavior students are invited to
submit screenshots of problematic
behavior which are in turn shared to an
audience of sometimes
thousands online they'll allow people to
submit anonymous info or images or
videos
they'll cross out the sender's name but
leave the racist person's contact info
basically for everyone to call them out
the result is a social media pile on
harassment docs and cancellation
brenda berry 16 a student at a catholic
day school in jacksonville florida
learned this firsthand
after posting some advocacy on instagram
and tick tock for the blue lives matter
movement miss berry whose father is a
police officer was met with vicious
harassment
her post spread across her peers
instagram feeds and quote my own friends
were commenting that i was a racist and
they can't support me
things travel fast i'm nervous about my
address getting leaked
question is this making things better is
this really making things better
it turns out that most of the political
change that happens in the united states
is based on friends talking to friends
and people talking to each other like
friends how often have you been
converted by people brow beating you
the answer is virtually never people are
not politically converted and they're
not converted from sin
by people brow beating them right fire
and brimstone type stuff
tends to get people motivated but it
doesn't actually convince people on the
other side
or people who have sinned that you are a
welcoming presence hoping to help them
instead what it does is alienate them it
makes them feel that you're a bad person
all the this entire culture is designed
to make a certain cadre of people feel
very good about themselves for doing
something very bad
they call out culture is a horrible
thing for the country it is a bad thing
for the country
calling people out privately and telling
them that you don't like that behavior
and as a friend you think it's a bad
idea that's a good thing
calling people out publicly in front of
a thousand strangers particularly kids
in order to quote unquote shame them is
an absurdity it's a moral absurdity
you're not doing anything good
you're not all you're doing is creating
a totalitarian culture in which people
are afraid to speak and then by the way
still say the bad things behind closed
doors because they've not been converted
from their original views
instead they've just been browbeaten
into silence so you didn't correct the
problem
all you did was push it underground and
that's really what's going to happen
here and it's ugly
it's bad and speaking of the call out
culture
and the the stupidity of call-out
mike gundy right who is the the oklahoma
coach oklahoma football culture
he was called out why because that guy
he wore a t-shirt with
oann on it one america news network he
had that t-shirt and he wore it and he
said he sometimes watches it that's very
bad so now
he's been forced to apologize first rule
of mob cancellation don't apologize
don't apologize i apologize for the
stuff that you have done that's actually
wrong
don't apologize for liking a particular
network
don't apologize for any of this stuff
because guess what apology is not gonna
be enough
and gundy's gonna find himself on the
chopping block partially because he
apologized
you the dirty little secret of canceled
culture is you don't have to be canceled
you don't have to be canceled you can
only cancel you in a free country only
you can cancel you
here's mike gundy apologizing yesterday
because he's afraid of losing his job
and then probably the apology will
prompt him to lose his job anyway here's
mike gundy from osu yesterday
once i learned how that network felt
about black lives matter
i was disgusted and knew it was
completely unacceptable to me
i want to apologize to all members of
our team
former players and their families for
the pain and discomfort
that has been caused over the last two
days
black lives matter to me our players
matter to me okay but blink a few times
if if you need
if it's an sos i mean these are these
are hostage videos essentially
right you can believe black lives matter
and also watch the news coverage on oia
in fact you can even you can watch all
sorts of cookie stuff it's a free
country you can do whatever you want
but this idea that this means that
you're racist because you watch stuff
that was not approved by the popular
and listen i'm not a huge fan of some of
the programming on onn there's some
people over there i'm friends with
there's some people i definitely am not
but the idea that you wore a t-shirt and
now you are canceled is absurd and again
the only way to escape the censure is to
repeat the mantras
i talked about this yesterday this is
unity through totalitarianism through
cultural totalitarianism
repeat and believe repeat the mantras
and you
will be protected and so you end up with
roger goodell
suggesting that he wants colin
kaepernick a man who suggested that the
killing of the lead terrorists in the
iranian regime
was just the murder of more black and
brown bodies by america right colin
kaepernick a guy who wore
socks with cops and pigs on them while
he was practicing back in 2015.
that guy is going to be the social guide
of the nfl according to roger goodell
again roger blink if you need us to
deploy a team
these hostage videos are just beyond
if he wants to resume his career uh in
the nfl
that obviously is going to take a team
to make that decision but
i welcome that uh support the club
making that decision
and encourage them to do that um if his
efforts
are not on the field but and continuing
to work in this space
uh we welcome to that to that table and
and to be able to help us
and guide us and help us make better
decisions about the kinds of things that
need to be done in communities
okay and great we need we i definitely
need colin kaepernick
who's wearing a che guevara t-shirt by
the way to talk about like oann t-shirt
very bad apologize che guevara t-shirt
you know actual communist mass murderer
totally fine totally fine good stuff
happening in our in our culture
right now and what exactly is the
narrative that you're supposed to buy
into you're supposed to buy into the
narrative that america's uniquely evil
tim kaine former vice presidential
candidate senator from virginia
uh he actually just said this straight
out on the on the floor of the senate
yesterday we'll get to that
in just one second first let us talk
about what you can get for dad this
father's day that he will love
i'm not talking about he needs another
tie or something i'm talking about the
steak
the steak omaha steaks so i had the
privilege of being sent maybe
a kosher omaha steak this thing is just
phenomenal phenomenal
omaha steaks has a limited father's day
offer for our listeners go to
omahasteaks.com
enter the coach shapiro into the search
bar to save 55
on the gift dad will love for 79.99 your
gift will include four naturally lean
top sirloin steaks
hand carved aged at least 21 days for
tenderness and flavor four premium
boneless chicken breasts four gourmet
jumbo franks and kielbasa sausages a
package of savory all beef meatballs
four perfectly browned potatoes raw
gratin four made from scratch caramel
apple tartlets in omaha steak's
signature seasoning packet this stuff
comes
and it is it is fresh it is delicious
hand carved and aged at least 21 days
for tenderness and flavor that is the
omaha steak's different
dad gets all that delicious food plus
the free pound of steak cut bacon
the amazing gift ready to be shipped
straight to dad's door in time for
father's day for just 79.99 makes me
wish i didn't keep kosher
this father's day send dad the gift he
really wants the meat
go to omahasteaks.com type shapiro in
the search bar
say 55 when you send the summer sizzle
pack for 79.99
and get free steak cut bacon with your
order don't wait head on over to
omahasteaks.com
type shapiro in the search bar to order
the summer sizzle pack for father's day
today
go check them out right now okay we're
going to get to tim kaine and the
narrative you're supposed to repeat all
the slogans you are supposed to repeat
and and how we're making the world a
better place by changing
snap crackle and pop on the rice
krispies packaging very very important
stuff solving racism
one branding matter at a time we'll get
to that momentarily first
this year um it's been like eight years
this year it's been a crazy year like
every day
i thought that the news cycle had
magnified tremendously since trump took
office and then this year happened and
it turns out that we are just living on
a hamster wheel of news
well if you can't get enough of the
actual news not the crap you get from
nbc news the activist journalists have
left but if you want
you know right wing opinion journalism
and you want the straight facts told to
you from a conservative point of view
go check out dailywire.com right now and
get a reader's pass you get access to
exclusive op-eds from us your podcast
hosts as well as guest writers and
in-depth analysis from our dailywire
reporters on top of our regular breaking
news i have a brand new article out
today
on the totalitarian subculture that has
taken over the mainstream culture
our memberships here this reader's pass
it's already a bargain at three bucks a
month but if you join today you get your
first month
for 99 cents you also get access to our
mobile app you receive push
notifications for breaking news and
special content
and you can join the community of daily
wire members who are actively commenting
and discussing our content with each
other that is mobile ad free access to
all of the daily wire news
exclusive op-eds all of our podcasts on
the mobile app all for the low price of
one dollar
best of all your dollars are getting you
the news you need without the left to
spin so
head on over to dailywire.com subscribe
and join today also
when you're a subscriber you get to ask
questions during our backstage lives we
have it backstage so yesterday i had an
all-access
which let's be frank it's amazing people
love it i sing random songs in random
voices
chris matthews did make an appearance to
sing music of the night actual things
that happened on all access
live backstage a little different we
actually talk about issues it's me and
jeremy boring
michael knowles and andrew clavin maybe
a couple special guests
we're having one tomorrow thursday 3 30
pacific 6 30 p.m eastern
we have a backstage so make sure that
you subscribe now so you get access to
all of these magnificent glories
also also please go pick up a copy of my
new book pre-order a copy of my new book
how to destroy america in three easy
steps comes out july 21st
never have i written a book that is more
relevant i mean this book is like right
on the money relevant i wrote it back in
december january
before the pandemic and then the
pandemic hit i thought oh this book is
probably going to be kind of back
shelved because
after all we can't really argue over a
pandemic can we wrong
wrong guy was it turns out that all of
the seething issues
underneath american politics the
destruction of america's core philosophy
the destruction of her history
the destruction of her culture of rights
all of that is first and forefront in
the minds of most americans these days
my book is not just an expose of that it
is a rebuttal
to all of these very very bad ideas that
you are seeing promulgated in the public
sphere it's called how to destroy
america in three easy steps i think it's
a useful book it is not just a vitally
a vitally relevant book it is a useful
book as well how to destroy america in
three easy steps go pre-order it right
now at dailywire.com that's
dailywire.com you can pick it up at
amazon as well
or at any other bookseller it's coming
out july 21st so order it now to make
sure you get
your copy you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
alrighty so tim what is the narrative
that you must believe and repeat the
narrative you must believe and repeat is
that all of american history is rooted
in bigotry and evil all of america's
institutions are bigoted and evil and
that america is uniquely evil
because what you can't do is
contextualize the united states you
can't contextualize our history you can
point out
that america is was not unique in in
allowing slavery america was unique in
working to get rid of slavery western
civilization is unique in that way it
took western civilization to end slavery
slavery still exists in many non-western
parts of the world today
okay like on mass officially saudi
arabia didn't abolish slavery until 1963
guys
okay like a hundred years after the
civil war it took western civilization
and
western civilization is uniquely good
because of the good stuff it did
western civilization is like the rest of
humanity in terms of all the bad stuff
it did it is uniquely good in terms of
the good stuff that it did
but for the left the narrative is that
america is uniquely evil
and so this prompts people like tim
kaine to say something so historically
ignorant is almost beyond belief he says
that america
created slavery like the united states
created
he doesn't say just america the united
states created slavery now that's an
absurdity on its face
first of all the united states didn't
actually form until 1776.
until then it was british colonies right
so even if you believe the 1619 project
the united states inherited slavery
from colonists who had been there for
150 years but as it turns out he's not
even right about this
slavery in the western hemisphere did
not originate with americans
it didn't originate with british
colonists but here's tim kaine being a
complete and utter buffoon because he
has a complete and utter buffoon who's
about to go
stage a hold up on a train apparently
he's always wearing these bandanas
he can't just get a regular man's gotta
wear the bandana it looks like he's
gonna participate in a hold up
anyway here was tim kaine remember this
guy was almost the vice president of the
united states
here he was yesterday the first
african-americans into the english
colonies came to
point comfort virginia in 1619 they were
slaves they've been captured against
their will
but they landed in colonies that didn't
have slavery
there were no laws about slavery in the
colonies at that time
the united states didn't inherit slavery
from anybody we created it
it got created by the virginia general
assembly and the legislatures of other
states it got created by the court
systems
in colonial america and sense that
enforced
fusion of slave laws it was we created
it
we created it he says we created it and
maintained it over centuries in my
lifetime we finally stopped the
practices we've never gone back to undo
it
i know i feel like we've undone the
legal regimes that allowed slavery i
feel like we undid that a while ago
and also we've spent the last 50 years
undoing the regimes of jim crow
it feels like he says stopping racist
practices after 350 or 400 years but
then taking no effort to dismantle them
is not the same as truly combating
racist racism taking no steps to
dismantle them
we've literally spent every waking hour
in the american federal government
trying to dismantle
jim crow and what does he think the
civil rights act was
seriously we spent 5 trillion on poverty
programs that were largely designed by
their creators
in order to alleviate a lot of the
disproportionate impact of things like
jim crow
also tim kaine is dead wrong on the
history in order to paint america's
uniquely evil he has to ignore the fact
that slavery has been the actual rule
rather than the exception across
all of human history it existed for the
greeks it existed for the romans it
existed for the ancient hebrews it
existed in native american tribes by the
way
pre-existing the coming of western
civilization
is british colonists not americans who
imported slaves to america
spanish colonists held slaves in the new
world long prior to 1619
they began importing african slaves to
hispaniola which is now cuba in 1501
a hundred years prior to the arrival of
british colonists
the first african slaves arrived in
spanish florida in 1526.
slavery was not uncommon among native
american tribes either
captives were regularly taken and made
into slaves for particular tribes
slavery was common in latin america and
in mesoamerica
so this idea like the idea that america
is uniquely evil is something that tim
kaine has to rely upon and if you don't
repeat and believe
then it's because you are unwoke you are
unwoke repeat
and believe repeat and believe just
absolute insanity
but but again bad history lies at the
root of all this by the way people in
the democratic party don't even know
their history
hysterically i mean this is really quite
funny a top mainstream fact checker
wrote on tuesday
you remember the democrats just a few
weeks ago it was actually last week
they were kente cloths you remember this
in the most obvious moments of cultural
appropriation in human history a bunch
of old white democrats who couldn't even
get up after kneeling
knelt while wearing kente claws which
again if mitt romney had worn one to a
black lives matter rally he would have
immediately been called out as an old
white dude trying to appropriate
cultural symbolism nancy pelosi does it
in hero of the republic hero and of the
republic
and well turns out that according to a
top mainstream fact-checker
kensei cloths were quote historically
worn by an empire involved in the west
african slave trade
whoops usa today fact-checked the
following statement from a facebook user
yesterday the democrats were kente
scarves and knelt down for their photo
ops so check this out kente cloth was
worn by the ashanti
it's made of silk so the affluent wore
it the ashanti were also known as slave
owners and traders
whoops the usa today rated the claim
true saying that the kente cloth was
historically worn by the asante people
of ghana who were involved in the west
african slave trade
well that's that's awkward that's
awkward um
yeah it turns out that slavery is not
unique to america and also if you're
gonna culturally appropriate do it
better democrats
really really well done but the good
news is that we are fixing all the
things all the things that are really
generating racism
in america those are the things we have
to fix so
quaker oats has now decided to drop its
antromycma brand
because it was stereotypical and based
on antebellum
stereotypical images of black people
that's fine you want to drop the brand
i'll do the good really seriously enjoy
yourself that's fine quaker oats can do
exactly what it wants i also hope that
they drop the the quaker oat brand
because that is also based on a
stereotype about quakers being honest as
the day is long and all of this
but dropping the antibiotic more power
to you want to do it
fine but if are we really going to
pretend that people have been eating
like the pancake batter from aunt jemima
for years
and that this evinced that this
evidenced some sort of toxic racism
i mean i don't want to speak for
everybody but i feel like
anchor mama's cake batter and and
pancake they're kosher
i feel like i've been eating that for a
long time and it has never once occurred
to me
that that race has anything to do with
the pancake batter
like me again you want to get rid of a
stereotypical symbol enjoy but are we
going to pretend that this is making
like a real difference in american life
because if so you're an idiot
like if you really believe that racist
racism solves we got rid of the ancient
mimosa
we're not we're not just doing that by
the way apparently kellogg's cereal
boxes
have been added to the list of
supposedly racist symbols by a disgraced
leftist former politician in the uk this
according to breitbart
fiona us onasanya a former labour party
mp
who's kicked out of parliament by uh her
own voters
has called on kellogg's to justify why
rice krispies is represented
by three white boys while the cocoa pops
the cocoa puffs mascot is a monkey
yes clearly kellogg's
there are no words there are no words
solving racism by going after the white
elves all the white elves on the rice
krispies box solving racism
now here's the here's the part that's
that's the most idiotic about all of
this
there are certain areas of american life
where policy can be made
that actually reduces racial divides but
because imaging this is a perfect
example of this
because image and message matters a hell
of a lot more than actual policy outcome
you end up with crappy policy truly
bleepy policy
bleepy being a four-letter word that
begins with s and ends with it
okay this is a truly bleepy policy so
the university of california
dropped the s.a.t and the act why
because it turned out that
disproportionately
black and hispanic students weren't
doing all that well on the sat and the
a.c.t
and so for a long time there's been a
bugaboo of the left that the test is
racist
it can't be that people are
underachieving for a variety of reasons
including
bad educational environment no it's got
to be that the test is racist
there's only one problem there's only
one problem the uc system
actually did a study a 228-page report
and that 228-page report which was
loaded with hundreds of displays of data
from the uc's various admissions
department
according to richard bernstein at real
clear investigations found that the sat
and the act actually helped
increase black hispanic and native
american enrollment at the system's ten
campuses
the report recommended that their use be
continued
why because it turns out the real reason
that black and hispanic students were
not getting into the uc system is
because their grades were not high
enough
so it turns out that the sat and the act
actually militated against
the worse the the worst use of of things
like grades so they say you want more
black hispanic students keep using the
sat
and the ac doesn't matter that it has
disproportionate results it's even more
disproportionate when you look at grades
so keep using the sat and the act but
the uc system
because they want to say that the test
is racist even if the evidence shows
that it absolutely is not racist
they're getting rid of the s.a.t and the
a.c.t
eddie kamal a professor of education at
uc riverside co-chair of the faculty
task force
said in a zoom interview that quote many
of us thought the process might be a
political one
he said there were several very
prominent figures with public statements
made pretty clear their opposition to
tests even before the task force
started its undertaking the region's
vote was kind of preordained it was 23
to nothing
23 to nothing there was not a single
person
in the uc system who voted to keep the
sat in the act despite
factual data provided by admissions
departments showing that the act and the
sat actually
made more black and hispanic students
eligible for the ucs
so the regions decided to get rid of the
sat and the act
maria anguiano whose one region said i
very much appreciate the task force's
work and the database i put together but
i also believe in peer review as part of
the research process
there's been decades of research showing
that sat scores are mostly correlated
with wealth and privilege
so i can't support the use of this tool
it's exclusionary and a filtering
mechanism ironically of course the sat
and the act and the college boards were
actually
designed to prevent privilege from being
utilized because it turns out that jews
italians and irish
and people from asian countries were
scoring better on those tests and it was
granting them access
above and beyond the sort of waspy
admission systems that had heretofore
existed at many major universities
so they just ignored the data well done
everybody
according to that report by the way the
uc system in 2018 admitted
22 613 applicants with weak grades but
strong sat scores
a quarter of those students were members
of underrepresented minorities or urms
nearly half were low-income or
first-generation students
breaking down the numbers 24 of
hispanics 40 to blacks 47
of native americans who gained
admissions to the uc did so because of
their sat scores
not despite them according to the task
force the original intent of the s.a.t
was to identify students who came from
outside relatively privileged circles
who might have the potential to succeed
at university said the report
this original intent is clearly being
realized at the uc
but instead because it's more important
to say that the sat
is racist because of its
disproportionate outcome
because that's deeply deeply important
they just got rid of the sat in the act
which actually hurts minority kids
because again the message is more
important than actually helping minority
kids by the way
it is also worth noting that bigotry is
perfectly allowed so long as you're
perfectly woke
as part of the messaging it's perfectly
okay to be openly anti-jewish
i mean beyond the the obvious of bill de
blasio ignoring anti-semitism in his own
city there have been a bevy
a bevy of of various
of various pro-black lives matter
celebrities who are approvingly posting
videos of louis farrakhan chelsea
handler posted a video of
louis farrakhan who's just a vicious
anti-semite she said a fair con
statement on racism from an old clip of
the phil donahue show
was powerful when a commenter asked her
if she would single
single out for praise some out of
context statement of hitler's she argued
farrakhan's hate was different because
quote he is just responsible for his own
promotion of anti-semitic beliefs
they are very different so anti-semitism
is just an opinion some people might
hold
it is not evidence of being hateful by
the way
a bunch of other celebrities then came
out and support jennifer aniston
jennifer garner michelle pfeiffer they
all voiced support for handler after she
tweeted out louis farrakhan so certain
types of bigotry okay certain types
of uh non-bigotry like the s.a.t and the
act absolutely not only the message
matters guys
only the message matters now you want to
see full scale
how only the message matters point out
the fact that donald trump yesterday
signed a a an executive order that
changed some policing tactics in the
united states
so he put out this long executive order
and the executive order does things
like certifying independent
credentialing bodies that are designed
to address certain topics and reviews
like policies and training regarding use
of force and de-escalation
techniques to make it to set up a
federal database so that people who are
bad cops are known
throughout the united states that they
can
they can set standards for
certifications
that demonstrate that the state or local
law enforcement agency's use of force
policies prohibit the use of chokeholds
except in situations where the use of
deadly force is allowed by law
right so all of this is is policy that
many on the left should be very
comfortable with right i mean it is it
is pushing for added funding for mental
health and homelessness and addiction
it is attempting to get rid of certain
policing tactics
it's an attempt to make bad cops more
answerable and less able to shift from
department to department i mean that's
what the executive order does
okay but president trump in the process
of this didn't rip into the police as
racist and that's the message the media
wanted to take away
that's the message the media wanted to
take away so president trump yesterday
he said listen
we want to make the cops better at their
jobs and give them more tools and
hold them to a higher standard but if
you remove cops the law-abiding get hurt
which is obviously true by every
available social science statistic
americans want law and order they demand
law and order
they may not say it they may not be
talking about it but that's what they
want
some of them don't even know that's what
they want but that's what they want
and they understand that when you remove
the police
you hurt those who have the least
the most okay he's exactly right about
this but people
instead of embracing the executive order
and also embracing the message that you
need the cops
the media decided that the big story
here is that trump wasn't repeating the
message he wasn't repeating the messages
they wanted him to repeat
right so the the headline at the
washington post was trump signs order on
policing but democrats and activists say
it falls far short
of what is needed the headline from nbc
on trump's executive order
suggested that trump signs order on
police reform but says nothing about
racism
okay so it's all what he doesn't say
it's all what he doesn't say
it's it's an absurdity so there are some
people who are at least honest about
this right van jones he says some
progress has been made here
at least van jones is honest about this
there is a new floor a higher floor for
congress to now depart from
that includes law enforcement support
for for for data
for de-escalators for better training
and against chokeholds
i think progress has been made muddied
by i think a speech
that was you know really i think you
know
over the line in a lot of ways if you're
trying to go for unity but i think the
speech goes away over time
i think the progress that the people
have made in getting even the trump
white house the republicans and now law
enforcement along with democrats
uh to take steps forward is really
powerful
hey van jones got trended for this on
twitter for giving credit for the
executive order the more typical view
from the left was that of maya wiley on
msnbc who said her big issue was not
what was in the order but the fact that
there were a bunch of white people
signing it
jeff sessions and and donald trump
himself
have long since the beginning of this
administration
made clear that they are on the side of
lawless policing in a law and order
framework
and he just did that again andrea you
know we have to stop and take one
really one slow down for a minute on the
optics of that press conference all i
saw
were white faces when we're talking
about black body
ah there we go there we go so it doesn't
matter the contents of what was said
all that matters is the color of the
faces makes perfect sense makes perfect
sense this is all making for a better
society the message matters more
than the actual policy helping people
come second to actually hurting people
right that's all that matters hurting
people who don't repeat the right
message that's the important thing
that's the important thing making
society better one one
one castigation at a time well done
everybody
okay time for a quick thing that i hate
and then we'll do a quick thing
that i like so quick thing that i hate
today
so i this is amazing so anthony fauci
right national institutes of health
and infectious diseases right anthony
fauci
had said very early on that masks are
not particularly effective and this clip
went around masks are not effective
and it turns out masks are actually
incredibly effective that countries that
have used masks have seen
very little regression in terms of covid
cases
that masks help prevent spread and
transmission of this stuff that if
everybody wore a mask
transmission would drop very close to
zero the masks are
maybe the best tool that we have in the
absence of of other drugs that could be
used here
okay so anthony fou so why exactly were
they recommending that we not use masks
because anthony factor said we can't
trust the american people the american
people would have gone out and bought
masks for themselves
and then they would not have been
available for medical health
professionals so we lied to people
we lied to people well done so you had
more community spread because
the federal government decided to lie to
people don't trust people lie to them
well done anthony fauci
the public health community and many
people were saying this
were concerned that it was at a time
when personal protective equipment
including the n95 masks
and the surgical masks were in very
short supply
and we wanted to make sure that the
people namely the health care workers
who were brave enough to put themselves
in harm ways
to take care of people who you know were
infected
with the coronavirus and the danger of
them getting infected
we did not want them to be without the
equipment
that they needed so
um that's a so they lied they lied
really good stuff
trust your public health experts except
when they're openly lying to you in
order to achieve a certain policy result
and this is this is a very bad way of
governing and wouldn't matter if there's
a republican or democrat it's a very
very bad way of governing meanwhile the
media continue to do their best to to
seed panic all over the country so they
weren't panicked last week when tens of
thousands of people were out in the
streets
that's all for the good right you have a
black trans matters lives matters
movement in brooklyn
and you've got 40 000 people out there
but you got some kids playing in
williamsburg gotta stop there gotta weld
the playground shut now it's panic time
and where is it panic time well where do
you think it's panic time florida texas
and arizona yeah pounding time in
florida no
here's the question not the number of
positive tests that come back
the question is what are the
hospitalization rates okay when we
reopened the question
flattening the curve was never about
stopping the spread of the disease
entirely
flattening the curve was about
preventing the overwhelm of our
healthcare system i said this one
million times on the program and i know
we've been moving the goal post
radically
i mean like all over the field to the 20
yard lines the 10 yard lines the 6 to
the 50 yard line
like all over the dam field we're now
way off the field right we've moved to a
separate field
we've moved to a different location
entirely with the goalposts the original
purpose of flattening the curve
was to prevent the hospital system from
being overwhelmed it is not being
overwhelmed in florida it is not being
overwhelmed in texas it is not being
overwhelmed in arizona it doesn't matter
the media are now covering this stuff
without any sort of real context so the
headline from the new york times is
florida texas and arizona all set
records for the most cases they have
reported
in a single day they also set records
for the most number of tests they gave
in a single day
okay so the actual question is what is
the positivity rate and what's the
hospitalization rate because even if the
positivity rate is high maybe it's a
bunch of young people coming in with
mild cases
that doesn't mean that the hospital
system is going to be overwhelmed i
don't care if somebody gets covered
and then they have like a fever for for
a few days and they're fine because
they're 20.
like that's not something you should
deeply just as i don't care if somebody
gets the flu and they're out of work for
a couple of days that's
that's not a huge that's not something
that is earth-shattering news
right that is not that is not the
destruction of the american healthcare
system or the rise in death
right what we really ought to be worried
about is preventable death meaning the
overwhelm of the healthcare system that
was that area above the line
in the high curve right that's what
we're all worried about there's no
evidence that florida arizona or texas
are being overwhelmed
according to the new york times however
the virus continued its steady spread
across the sun belt on tuesday with
state officials in arizona florida and
texas
all reporting their largest one-day
increases in new cases yet
florida reported 2783 new cases texas
arizona 2392. the new daily highs came
as all three states have increased
testing and moved swiftly to ease social
distancing restrictions and allow more
businesses
to reopen governor ron desantis of
florida attributed the uptick to more
widespread testing noting at a news
conference tuesday the state was not
only testing far more people than it did
earlier in the spring but was also going
into high-risk environments and testing
farm workers
and migrant workers and finding new
cases but epidemiologists have said the
numbers
suggest increased transmissions well you
would expect there would be increased
transmissions they're more people out in
public obviously
but that does not necessarily mean that
the state has to shutter again
he said you have to have society
function which of course is exactly
right
now again the notion that this is going
to
overwhelm the health care system and we
have to shut down again you're seeing
the media starting to stump
for all of this how about this how about
the fact that nationwide the positivity
rate remains essentially the same as it
was since late may
it's a little bit different in some of
the states it is not different
nationally basically it's receded in new
york
it has increased in some places that
have opened up elsewhere but
the death rates have not increased and
the hospitalizations have not increased
to the point where we are worried about
it
this is why mike pence is saying there
isn't a coronavirus second wave
he mike pence has an editorial in the
wall street journal today he says
well talk of an increase in cases
dominates cable news coverage more than
half of states are actually seeing cases
decline and remain stable
every state territory and major
metropolitan area with the exception of
three have positive test rates under 10
10 and in the six states that have
reached more than a thousand new cases a
day
increased testing has allowed public
health officials to identify most of the
outbreaks in particular settings prisons
and nursing homes
and meat packing facilities and then
contain them lost in the coverage is the
fact that today
less than six percent of americans
tested each week are found to have the
virus
cases have stabilized over the past two
weeks the average daily case rate across
the us
has dropped down to about 20 000 from 30
000 in april and 25
000 in may the truth is we've made great
progress over the past four months
it says we've expanded our supply of
crucial medical equipment
we've we've expanded our tests to
roughly 500 000 per day
we've increased personal protective
equipment we've also made great progress
on developing therapeutics in a vaccine
last month gilead sciences announced it
would donate 940 000 vials of its new
drug remdesaphere to treat more than 120
000 patients in the u.s under operation
warp speed
and by the way it is worth noting in
other good news that
is not getting all the press that it
should it turns out that a very very
common steroid i asked my wife about
this because of course she is
a doctor i asked my wife about this it
turns out that a very very common
steroid dramatically reduces death
in people who are on ventilators or on
oxygen this is according to the new york
times
and again the media are reporting this
but it's not getting the kind of
coverage as spike we're all going to die
right really that was the there was a
story yesterday i think it was from
was it from the new york times i can't
remember the source about how if you
flush a toilet it's gonna it's gonna
flush these germs three feet in the air
and stay there forever and you're all
gonna die never flush a toilet again
great ideas guys how about this how
about you try to measure how many people
have been infected by flushing toilets
before you panic everybody
i mean we keep we heard for for weeks
that you were gonna get it from picking
up an amazon package at your front door
okay turns out that's not true nobody's
getting it from surfaces people are
getting it from being in close contact
with human beings in closed areas and
breathing on them
because the viral load on surfaces is
just not that high
the new york times again this is good
news in an unexpected sign of hope
amid the expanding pandemic scientists
at university of oxford said on thursday
an inexpensive and commonly available
drug reduced deaths in patients with
severe cova-19
if the finding is borne out the drug a
steroid called dexamethasone would be
the first treatment shown to reduce
mortality in several
severely ill patients had doctors been
using the drug to treat the sickest
covenant 19 patients in britain from the
beginning
up to 5 000 deaths could have been
prevented according to researchers
the reason that they didn't is because
using a steroid
has the effect of suppressing the immune
system and people were afraid they
didn't know what was more important to
strengthen lung function or to
strengthen immune system function
and it turns out that immune system
function might have been the problem in
many of these cases the immune system
overcompensating
in severe cases the virus directly
attacks cells lining the patient's
airways and lungs
the infection can also prompt an
overwhelming immune response that is
just as harmful
the drug appears to reduce inflammation
caused by the immune system protecting
the tissues
in this study dexamethasone reduced
deaths of patients on ventilators by
one-third
by one-third which by the way would be
like the overall death rate because
virtually everybody who died or a lot of
people who died ended up on ventilators
before dying
by one-third that is a major major
downgrade
deaths of patients on oxygen by
one-fifth which can make sense because
most patients who are on oxygen don't
end up dying
right once you end up on a ventilator
there is a good shot you are dead of
covid 19. but if you can reduce that by
one third
then you're talking about a reduction in
overall death rate that is extraordinary
this is really really good news and by
the way
this is this if this does cut deaths i
mean this is dr atul gawande right she
was not on the right surgeon and author
he wrote on twitter
he said it will be great news if this
really does cut deaths by one-third and
ventilated patients with kovid
19 it would be great news i mean you
were talking about then
moving this thing down closer not quite
two but closer to the deadliness level
of the flu which would be really really
important
why is that not the big news today why
is the big news that if you go out to a
restaurant you stay six feet away from
somebody you're gonna die
there is no overwhelming of the hospital
system that is going on in the united
states right now there's increased
testing the increased testing is
partially responsible for the detection
of increased covet activity there the
the extension of hospitalization rates
is not radical we are not seeing the
system being overwhelmed
that doesn't mean you should stop being
careful you should continue to be
careful everyone should continue to be
careful but the notion that we are on
the verge of a second wave spike and
everybody's gonna die
is just not borne out by the evidence
okay time for a quick thing that i like
so if you haven't checked out the
verdicts with ted cruz with my friend
senator ted cruz and my not friend
michael moles then you definitely should
so
michael knowles is the guest host with
senator cruz and they talk about
all of the issues of the day they bring
in people from the trump administration
other members of the senate to talk
about what exactly is going on on
capitol hill frankly i haven't seen
anything that goes quite as deep into
what exactly is going on behind the
closed doors of capitol hill better than
the verdict with ted cruz here's a
little bit of a taste
something i've noticed just on these
shows is you hear so much about how
personal relationships and these sort of
unplanned
moments can really shift the path of
policy in the country
well it does but i think the other thing
is the interesting thing so
so ted goes come on i'm going over to
see the president you need to come with
me we need to talk to him about
obamacare
and i'm going okay well you got an
appointment no no we're just going i
mean
and so so you get this and you go okay
we're going to drop in on the president
of the united states and talk
policy on a saturday by the way we
literally ubered over i mean it was
kind of when you're sitting there going
it's a miracle secret service didn't
shoot us
but it's all about one relationships
you're exactly right michael but the
other part of that is
is about tenacity it's making sure
you're tenacious about what you know is
good for the american people
and you're willing to fight that fight
and and ted obviously
has uh not only a career of doing that
all righty so check it out the verdict
with ted cruz and um
michael mills is there too so try to
ignore the fact that nols is there and
uh just enjoy the fact that this is real
insider stuff from the people who are
playing the game on capitol hill
alrighty we'll be back here later today
with two additional hours of content
otherwise enjoy the rest of your day and
we'll see you here tomorrow for your
next assignment
this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
supervising producer mathis glover and
robert sterling assistant director pablo
wydowski
technical producer austin stevens
playback and media operated by nick
sheehan
associate producer katie swinnerton
edited by adam sciovitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by nico geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2020.
you know the matte wall show it's not
just another show about about politics i
think there are enough of those
already out there we talk about culture
because culture drives
politics and it drives everything else
so my main focuses are
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about hope
you'll give it a listen
you